What kind of medication do you have
to take if you're going to go there?
Because you have to take
some anti-malarial stuff,
right? I'm a pin cushion.
Like I had so many shots
and pills and you know,
like the preventative, obviously I
actually don't do malaria medication.
I just cover up. Um, because
it messes with your brain.
I don't know if you know that. Like I,
they say the new modern ones aren't bad,
but the malarone like you
have hallucinations at night,
you have crazy sweats like,
especially if you're in hot sun. So I,
I would rather be more focused,
especially if I'm working with reptiles
or stuff like that, that can, you know,
[inaudible] me. So I try and try to stay
away from it and just cover up. Wow.
Is there a specific type of clothing
that's like anti mosquito repellent
clothing or anything like that?
I just do long sleeves and some bug spray.
And do you do a mask as well now? No.
That's silliness. Really look silly.
It does look, so, no, I just do,
you know, good old deet. God.
That's stuff's gotta be
bad for you too though.
It melts you like if you get
it on like say these things,
it will melt the painting, the paint
off of the headphones. It's so strong.
It's probably worse than the mouth.
Have you ever used a thermostat?
What did they call the m
fucking is it called Thermacell?
I think that's was called. Um, it's
um, it's a device that heats up.
It's got like an element inside
of it and like a little bit,
a little canister of gasoline and you put
these sheets and it releases this very
fine mist. Oh No. Kind of smell and
mosquitoes fucking hate it. No Way. Yeah,
we used it in Alberta. Alberta has very
aggressive mosquitoes when they're out,
when they're out, they're out. It's
like clouds of them, right? Yeah.
Cause some of your life for like
three months. Right? It's like Alaska.
There've been a last night. It's the
worst. Mosquitoes have ever seen.
Crazy like pick you
up. Yeah. They're like,
there's size of pigeons and
their funnel everywhere. Totally.
And when a fishing with my friend
Ari and we pulled up the, the,
the car and we'd got out of the car
and we opened the car door and within
seconds a swarm of mosquitoes
was inside the car. It's insane.
We were screaming like, what
the fuck? This is crazy.
And it's like something out of,
it's a Stephen King movie.
There's clouds and they, I,
I, yeah, that's why you asked
me what I'm scared of it.
That fucking clouds of
mosquitoes, man. Well,
we're very fortunate we don't have
malaria here in the United States. Yup.
Absolutely. If it made its way
over here somehow, you know, I, um,
I wear this fabric. You're talking
about Thermacell called hex.
Hex. Exactly. And, um,
I wear for a lot of reasons because I
definitely feel it helps me get closer to
wildlife, but I've noticed mosquitoes
do not like it real. So that's,
that's what a heck suit is for,
for people that don't know
what we're talking about.
So it's this interwoven carbon grid that
actually holds the body's electrical
energy and capacity, like
the door of microwave oven,
like a faraday cage. Right.
And so you naturally admit electrical
energy and then when you wear this
clothing,
it's got this conductive carbon grid.
And when you touch the ground or something
at grounds it and releases all the
energy. So birds migrate or
using. Yeah, there you go.
Now has it had been proven
that this stuff actually work?
I mean it has been proven that it has
an effect on the electrical energy that
you released,
but has it been proven that the animals
can actually recognize that electrical
energy and with certain animals?
Yes.
So we know that electro
reception is certain wildlife's
capable out of birds use
it to migrate. Sea Turtles
Use magnetic poles to migrate.
Um, they just discovered,
I believe 2014 that lobsters antenna
have electrical detective sensors or
electro reception is the word. Um, so it's
proven on some things, not everything.
You know,
our understanding of animal behavior and
animal adept till ability is constantly
growing. So it's passive,
you know what I mean?
I wear it because it's
a passive technology.
It's like I'm going to
wear a shirt anyway.
Why not wear one that
might or might not help?
So I feel it helps my friend
John Dudley is a bow hunter. Yup.
Pretty famous bow hunting.
I know John. Yeah. Okay. And
He, and he swears by it. Yeah.
Yeah. He wears them constantly. He's like,
it makes a big difference. I think. So,
you know, like I'm, I'm not hunting,
I'm just trying to get close to stuff
and interact with it or find something.
But I feel it makes a difference.
Notice a difference personally,
especially with birds. Um,
I've noticed a huge difference.
I've noticed a huge
difference in the water.
Some mammals I've noticed a
difference. Um, but yeah, I like John.
I feel like it's, it helps me
get closer and you know, keeps,
keeps the energy down.
Do you know what I mean?
Like you're admitting all this energy,
you see this bear or whatever it is,
your heart's spikes, your adrenaline
goes and it keeps that in capacity.
So I think we sense that. I think
certain creatures sense that. And I,
I like to keep that out of
the equation. Right. The,
I guess it would be that there is
something coming off of your body and it
probably would be an advantage for
animals to be able to recognize that just
because we can't quantify it,
right.
And put it on a scale and weigh
out or something like that.
It's probably something going
on Predator prey, right?
Like if you're aligned and I'm
an, I'm an antelope and, uh,
my adrenaline spikes and my
heart's going and you know,
you're going to come for me, right?
But if that's out of the equation,
the energy stays reduced.